hello the Internet I'm gab I'm done
we're the slow mo guys I'm almost giddy
with excitement yeah I can't wait it's
got a rocket here we're we're here in
Indiana
at Purdue University where some very
smart students have made this rocket
yeah it's pretty cool this is a few
bottoms out there this is a G motor G
type motor and he uses the same solid
fuel as a space show by the solid rocket
booster yeah except it's made of bog
roll and plywood different slight
difference there yeah also this is
pretty cool the bottom part the rocket
motor goes from here to here yeah
by the time it gets to here it's got at
130 miles an hour and these things can
break the speed of sound so in like four
feet its accelerated to 130 miles now
yes yeah and it goes over a thousand
feet we're gonna need the fast camera
for this we are yeah let's yeah let's
send it to the moon absolutely well just
shy just a lot shy so for the close-up
we'll shoot on the V 25:11 at twenty
eight point five thousand frames per
second fast we're gonna need it very I
know we'll get the wide on the old the
odd 4k over there crisp Chris so we need
the crisp wide and the slow tight yes
sweet I've got a job as well this is
what I'm excited about you're gonna be
carrying behind something over there
I'll be filming I've got the key of
dreams oh look at that what you do is
very similar to the Space Shuttle yeah
you actually hook it up to a car all
right
NASA do this they sacrificed a car every
time you didn't know that back so I'm
gonna stick it in this little sort of
exciting pad and when the light goes off
I'll push go and hopefully that thing is
gonna absolutely just disappear yeah
boy Oh three two one
he's coming down
lovely
[Music]
[Music]
it's it's so much brighter than our
surroundings I kind of want to just do a
super dark one all right so you see like
it's basically obliterate all the
surroundings yes so we can see it's
slightly more detail I don't I think
it's still blow out white but you'll see
a little bit more so now we're gonna get
a close-up of that
it's very bright very Sparky so I'm
gonna move the camera in and I'm gonna
turn the exposure way down so it's
actually gonna be a very dark image
until the rocket ignites and then
hopefully we should see some lovely
detail there until the meaty part the
silver the rocket meat very close barely
even closer any even closer
I can get that and you in the same frame
it so this point in the video we're just
going to repeat the same rocket and I
was focused on getting that fast camera
right up in there for the extreme
closeup and the wide was kind of
secondary at this point we've already
got the white is gonna be the same for
this one so I don't have any footage of
this but I do have my mic audio of me
putting out this question does anyone
want to have a go on the phantom and
track the rocket get try give it a go so
one of the students volunteered and I
ran him through the whole thing I just
said follow the rocket up press the red
button within four seconds don't bother
looking at the screen look at it with
your eye and just jam the handle down
because it will be that fast and there's
not really any risk to it if the shot
doesn't work that's fine we've still got
the close-up he absolutely nailed it and
we'll see his shot in just a little bit
okay ready yeah
I think I mean the GoPro shot here is
life right okay right five four three
two one
how was this
they've just lost the GoPro it's not
even ours this time but by my
calculations that's for GoPro let's put
the casualty yeah another GoPro casually
[Music]
it looks like a much bigger shuttle
because it's so so it's like it's like a
really big one it's actually just got up
yeah miles an hour if it wasn't for the
PVC in diction - yeah that would look
like a NASA shop
could it but like a really accurate
model to person there yeah massive look
at that see that's where the exposure is
good here because supposedly old
exposure all of that would be white
there's actually yellow detail that is
like music we thought like rocket
raining bombs I love that your class
you know this I'll be annoyed
maybe use the Phantom before replace
death okay so you got windier and we
took some weight out at the top of that
last one because let's go faster and
further but it meant it kept falling
over so I had to put dictionaries on the
store in classics logo stuff yeah every
sandbags or anything useful only to have
two dictionaries dictionaries yeah yeah
slapping down but we are a university
that was awesome scary yeah we retrieved
the GoPro yes it was it was in a tree
you say we did we were filming we had
nothing to do with it we had a very
talented team of GoPro rescuers coming
just for that perfect was like 20 feet
in the branches apparently I thought
some of that footage was lovely can you
keep that row sorry point away I'm
amazed that they went so high that I had
time to trigger both cameras then run to
the DSLR pick it up and still see it in
this guy part from my job of pushing the
button I always try to find it because
at one point we're like 2,000 feet all I
could see was smoke no I just well
hopefully you enjoyed that video special
thanks to Purdue University in Indiana
for having us and uh you know letting us
launch rockets yeah that's class that's
probably the highest bog roll has ever
got right I feel free to follow us on
Twitter as well buy a shirt and
subscribe we got a second channel too oh
yeah usually I'm playing pranks on dan
he's not so happy about it but I have a
great time over there on the second
channel make up for that I'm gonna go
and play these Rockets again yeah and
you you do the camera stuff I'll clean
up alright